before this whole nonsense uh pandemic
broke out
you performed in huntsville alabama
on the same night as another event
and you described this as what you
thought was kind of a rough
point in your career my show was the
same night as
weiner dogs on ice
on ice that's correct i've been doing
this i think
22 years and i guess there is a part of
me a little surprised that 22 years down
the road i find myself in huntsville
alabama
competing against wiener dogs on ice
um who got the bigger draw that night
weiner dogs on ice wiener dogs on ice
did
i sold i sold well okay it was it was a
fun show i'm sure it was a great show i
just
well you cannot compete i like to be
honest that is my favorite dog i love i
love a
long-haired wiener dog so if i if i were
in huntsville alabama that night i
wouldn't have gone to my show i would
have been at
uh wiener dogs on ice i'm telling you
i don't think i cannot think of a single
show i've done
in my entire career that could compete
with a wiener dog that has tiny little
skates
strapped to its paws and then it's
shoved across the ice
do you think that's what was happening
how else could it what else could weiner
dogs on ice be
i mean i just assumed it was just their
little paws
um not being able to get a grip on the
ice and
and uh yeah but you feel like they were
actually
skating around i think when you say on
ice
you're almost legally obliged to have
escapes involved
otherwise you could say you know
uh whatever you could say hey it's amy
klobuchar on
ice and just whip her out onto an ice
rink and watch her slide around on her
ass
that's not a nice show
i'd go to that though you know what
so would i